[Music]
you're gonna teach us quickly how to eat
these noodles gentlemen do you want to
yes so partake in this is it okay if and
doing over here
of course all right what's in this we
want to know every ingredient is how
it's made this is a shoyu ramen with a
little bit of chicken and pork stock
right and we have the fresh ramen
noodles we have some pork char on top
with bamboo shoots
all right scallions yep so basically
when you eat a bowl of noodles in Japan
it comes out piping hot and you want to
eat it fast you're in a hurry right you
want to give respect to the track but no
he'd do it but that's like eating like a
dog that was the correct way what's
wrong like what he just saw you have to
I sort of you know you have to be one
with the ball bring up the noodles like
this be the ball Danny you the ball
slurp 50 slurp okay why is the slurping
important because it brings all the
aromas mm-hmm into your mouth mm-hmm
into your nose all the senses and the
louder you slurp the more respect you
give to the shop
[Music]
[Applause]
check out the original ramen burger when
you are into Los Angeles as for the
ingredients we have no idea
you